thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you on Thursday the
8th of December I'm James Hill the
spectator's diary editor coming up on
the show
can Rishi sunak keep his party together
the government has had to make several
u-turns over the last week I'll be
joined by James Forsyth and Katie Bulls
to discuss one person who will be
leaving politics is Matt Hancock the
former Health secretary has announced
that he'll be stepping down in the same
week as his version of what happened
during the pandemic has been published
are we speaking to journalists and
lockdown skeptic Isabel oakshott about
what it was like to co-author pandemic
diaries with Matt Hancock meanwhile in
Iran hundreds of people have been killed
by the government as the protests rage
on what will be the lasting impact of
these protests I speak to Paul wood also
today the battle of the Windsors enters
a new phase with the release of Harry
and Megan's Netflix documentary are they
intent of taking William and Kate down I
speak to Freddie gray and author Giles
brandreth and finally is your office
Christmas party coming back with a fury
I speak to spectator worlds Cara Kennedy
about the joys of breaking down office
hierarchies with the help of the festive
spirit and of course a lot of alcohol
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss
another episode
you can also subscribe to The Spectator
this Christmas and get the next 12 weeks
of print and online access as well as a
bottle of Paul Roger champagne all for
just 12 pounds this offer is available
to the UK only go to
www.spectator.com UK forward slash Santa
to subscribe
first up it's Richardson upcoming party
management issues over the last week the
prime minister's u-turned on subjects
from onshore wind to planning reform and
meanwhile Labor's on the offensive I
showed a chance that Rachel Reeves tells
Katie Bulls in this week's issue Katie
joins me now together our political
editor James Forsyth
James and Katie welcome to spectator TV
uh let's talk first about party
management problems and um James you
mentioned your column this week you talk
about the planning and the onshore win
rebellions um but these haven't been as
damaging for Richardson neck as perhaps
some recent rebellions for his two
predecessors why is that I've been
because these rebellions have been quite
contained to the specific issue planning
has always been difficult you know even
when Boris Johnson had that big majority
he faced uh rebellions on planning over
the housing algorithm and then over the
reforms more generally after church I
also think the housing rebellion was uh
was it was was clearly not a threat to
his leadership in that the person
leading into his abilities are backed in
very enthusiastically in both contests I
think the orange will win one was an
interesting development because it was
obviously Simon Clark putting down an
amendment to his successors bill it was
then signed by two previous Prime
Ministers Liz truss and Boris Johnson
but you know they have now got to a
compromise and I mean interestingly the
compromises essentially allows bees
onshore wind farms where communities won
them and interestingly you haven't seen
a kind of equal and opposite reaction
from the kind of anti-win farm people on
the other side of the party so
but it appears we've navigated their way
through that I I think the challenge is
always is that you know every all
legislation has to be able to get
through Parliament otherwise it's not
going to work but I think you know labor
of abused a lot of trying to attack
these amendments saying oh look you're
having to negotiate with your own party
you know all of this I think I think in
a way the question is you know can you
preempt these in future so you don't end
up having to have the negotiations you
know in such a public way seeing what's
coming down the track effectively and
alongside those kind of that need for
the Tories to take care this also should
be no labor have really stepped up their
game in Parliament we saw that this week
with Michelle known the amendment put
down in the House of Lords to um try and
get some of those documents revealed
over PPE contracts uh Katie you were
speaking to labors Rachel Reeves who
seems to have a bit of a spring and a
step um what was your interview like and
what was your sense of how laborer doing
at this stage of the parliament yeah I
mean I think it's hard for David not to
have us bring in their staff at the
moment if you look at the polling
they're consistently polling at least 20
points ahead
um I think Richardson has you know
narrowed the Gap by about Five Points uh
you know from this dress but we're still
talking about a huge labor majority of
this must be projected in a general
election and you have this week I think
Rachel Reeves is particularly happy
because
while we've seen it since taking over I
think that it's quite competitive now
again in the question of who you trust
more in the economy and the Tories
versus unique leads and samples
um you have a conference this week with
business coming out for labor and the
mission she's set herself in terms of
restoring trust and labor on the economy
and fiscal responsibility I think she
thinks that lots of things have happened
it's interesting in the interview so one
of the moments where she thought things
you know actually she has managed to you
know see some uh consequences of her
work was a labor conference when
um often leaders give a speech and you
know the bits where you expect people to
Cheers so the labor would be you know
our NHS and she had a line saying it and
that is why labor is the party of fiscal
responsibility and they've got a
standing ovation and she was not
expecting that so there's been a few
cents there but um in the interview she
is talking I think she distance herself
very much from corbinomics sharing is
hugely surprising you remember Rachel
Reeves is someone who refused to serve
under Jeremy corbyn not that he would
have asked her to do potentially
um so you know she and actually she was
seen so much being on the right of the
labor party that when uh kistama first
formed his shadow cabinet there were
some people saying she would get Shadow
Chancellor but it was seen as too
divisive actually in terms of the PLP
and so he first had analyst Dodds and
then after some time he moved in Rachel
Reeves and but she's saying everything
would be fully costed in the manifesto
and eventually saying that will mean
that some things that they would like to
do something similar kiss diamond said
in his interview and you know will not
happen straight away and some of those
pledges will not take place and then I
thought was quite interesting was I said
well Jeremy Hunt he when he took over in
number 11 he called lots of his
predecessors and took advice including
quasi quattang despite the circumstances
of Jeremy Hunt coming in and which was
obviously uh this trust asking quartz
gotten to go and he asked them for
advice who said did you do that before
my shadow chances what about John
McDonald and not the first protocol
instead she was much more positive about
uh George Osborne saying that she
thought if um if in power
kirstama and herself she'd like to take
some of the relationship that David
Cameron and George Osborne had of course
George Osborne was a shadow chancellor
who ended up being very successful in
that 2010 campaign and then thereafter
in government it seems from both your
pieces this week it's this question of
competence and trust and there seems to
be sort of tacit unspoken agreement
between the parties about who's more
trusted with the economy perhaps James
is that sort of the issue particularly
with the winter of discontent almost 2.0
beckoning with strikes I think it's a
precondition of any Tory Revival in the
polls that they show that they have a
grip and I mean these strikes are
there's an obvious challenge for the
government and to keep the country
functioning during these strikes and
then there's a political question about
where does the blame lie do people who
can't catch a train next week uh do they
say oh my word this is just another sign
that nothing works in Britain don't
blame the Tories for that or do they
think oh you know why couldn't they why
couldn't the rail unions have taken the
offer why couldn't they have accepted
the government's request for a kind of
Christmas Truce so the hospitality
industry doesn't get covered by these
strikes and I think that question of
blame is interesting I mean it's also
very striking that at the moment labor
are running as as all positions would
when they are as Katie said as far ahead
the polls out they're running a small
Target strategy so they are trying to
say that suggests the government is to
blame for the strike they call the
military the militant government they
call it you know it's just the
government wants to scapegoat nurses
what's wrong with the NHS but
um I haven't heard anyone on the labor
side suggest what kind of pay rise they
would be prepared to offer nurses yeah
you know uh Rachel Reed said at this
conference that Katie was just talking
about um talking about earlier but you
know she wasn't going to pluck a number
out of here this is very deliberate
ambiguity from labor and I mean there is
a real question here which is because of
these poll leads as you get closer to uh
an action day people start saying the
labor so how do your sums add up and
that I think is going to be the
challenge for labor because I think at
the moment all the things they are doing
and saying suggest that they intend to
go into that campaign basically saying
they're going to stick to the in not not
to every Dot and comment but basically
stick to the Tory spending class well of
course it's a 1997 strategy isn't it
kicking I was struck in your interview
with Rachel where she sort of brought up
the 1997 comparison between the assisted
places scheme abolition and this now
proposal to remove the chat status of
private schools uh to what extent is
labor kind of Reviving The 1970 playbook
in the hopes it'll take them from
opposition to government as did that was
the last time I think you can see a lot
of that and obviously hoping it's going
to be a 97 moment in terms of the
results too and I think this does some
caution for example you know kiss
drama's uh in Louisiana to say we're not
complacent but not complacent he's also
you know bardle his um advisors from
posting the poll leads and the WhatsApp
groups he's in I'm told but you can also
see labor slightly to James's Point not
wanting to be too bold
um and actually not wanting to give too
much away yet so there's obviously a
really key question which is yes Rachel
Reeves are saying a labor government
won't pledge you know huge spending once
at least that's the implication and
because she accepts the obr she she
accepts the fiscal framework
um but then uh you know I put to her
well do you think that taxes are too
high so she said taxes and working
people are too high so I said well in
which case if you know let's see if do
we really think labor going to go ahead
for these cuts that the Tories have
planned about an election so if it's
going to be higher taxes is it fair to
say labor would focus more on business
taxes than personal taxes now she
wouldn't get drawn too much on that but
she did go and say we would make fairer
decisions on tags and she also wouldn't
talk about closing loopholes and
therefore we're not yet at the point
where I think they would spell it out
but it seems to me that they would be
moving more towards business taxes if
you read between the lads of what
they're saying but
um as soon as you get into the detail
you get into tricky decisions and again
we didn't put it in the interview but on
strikes it was a very similar situation
which said today but where she won't get
into the specifics and that means it's a
much harder but if this party is about
to win a really big majority I think
they'll get in a situation nearer that
actually really do have to spell some of
these things out uh James what kind of
timeline is it here in the lead up to
the next election I mean what point do
labor have to this line about holding
refusing to give details on kind of tax
and spend plans on how much they would
pay in terms of wages and public
Spectrum Rising how long can that line
hold I think they will try and hold off
for quite for quite some time and I
think they will also argue but you know
look every a physical event is
accompanied by a new obr forecast so
these numbers move around so you can't
expect us to to go for specifics now and
they'll say I'm the ones revealing thing
about laborers if you look back to Liz
truss's mini budget is yes labor opposed
for example the abolition of the 45p
rate but they immediately spent that
money on something else they basically
accepted the envelope that this trust is
going through they're making very
different choices and I think that to my
mind suggests but labor are not going to
go down a kind of 1992 route of a kind
of Shadow budget you know the whole new
set of numbers I mean they're basically
you know they are basically gonna to
have some symbolically different choices
to victories on you know private school
fees that and things like that but not
but there's not going to be that much
substantial difference and I think it is
essentially like a kind of boxers clinch
I mean they don't want to give
Victoria's room to swing a punch I mean
that is what labor applying to do I've
got to ask my final question I think
it's probably my favorite line this
week's entire magazine which is in
Katie's interviews Rachel Rachel Reeves
sends out 3 200 Christmas cards each
year start signing in the summer is that
a record in Westminster do you know
anyone else who can beat that well so
I've asked around since so ahead of this
interview
um it was in Port Carlos house in
Parliament and we're just asking a few
people who saw what's the most
interesting thing you've heard about
Rachel Reeves when she and someone said
I heard she starts her Christmas card
list really early so okay let's give
that a go
um and then so we heard you started in
the summer so two right and then she
started going into
um 3200 all I have to point out ink
signatures so some leaders try and get
around this by doing a printed signature
and I have to say I put to very senior
politician I won't give away the game
just yet who uh will be in the Christmas
issue at the magazine you know how many
cards do you do and they were not near
Rachel Reeves number and they were also
quite impressed that she is obviously
putting the ink signature in which means
effectively I think she's almost running
a boot camp where anytime you have
asking if it's a Spare Time signing a
few Christmas cards to get free the
number and so I I as far as I know the
MPS are welcome to get in touch and
correct us and she is quite far ahead if
you take into account these are
personally signed well and please please
do get in touch and correctly wrong and
uh James and Katie thank you for joining
us
now then one person who's already
decided about politics is Matt Hancock
he said he'll step down in the next
election the same week as publishing his
pandemic Diaries which put forward his
side of the narrative on exactly what
happened when he was Health secretary so
what was it like for a passionate
lockdown skeptic to co-author his book
Isabel oakshop joins me now
Isabel welcome to spectator TV thank you
um thank you for coming in to discuss uh
your new book Thank You written with
Matt Hancock on the pandemic Diaries
um first question really what does it
like to work with Matt well that is not
an easy question to answer
um this is I work at town this is my
10th book so and each one is uniquely
traumatic every time I think the next
one can't be as bad I mean this one the
challenge was that it was so much longer
than I anticipated I'm in a standard
political book as you know is about 80
000 words now Matt's story was so
extraordinary uh and the detail was so
riveting
um that actually I had to indulge him
and let him run it a bit longer but when
I say a bit longer the book did end up
being twice the length that I wanted and
anticipated originally and probably half
the length that he would have liked and
you write it in this week's magazine
about uh how it was to deal with and one
of the things you had to do Contender it
was the government's own response to
this which is the redactions from the
cabinet office and he said it's almost
about 300 edits or tweaks or changes
what was Matt like dealing with those
and dealing with the cabinet office so I
always say to people that I work with
when I write books for and with people
that they shouldn't edit themselves
during the process while we're
discussing what we could put in the book
they should tell me everything and then
at the end we'll go through a process of
deciding what we can and can't get away
with in this case we did that but then
there was another process which was
submitting the manuscript to the cabinet
office because he had to do that under
ministerial rules rules that apply to
people who were in senior positions and
back they came with almost
300 things that they objected to and in
some cases there were quite minor things
and you know I wasn't going to die in a
ditch over them neither was Matt you
know there was a number of the points
they made you felt well actually that's
quite reasonable you know we can accept
that we've got to give them some wins
there are a number of others that and
you're going to ask me what they were
I'm not going to tell you on this
occasion that literally made my blood
boil certain things that they wanted us
to change that I thought were entirely
unreasonable and then there was another
category that they wanted taken out
which were just really the objection was
betraying certain kind of mischievous
um confidences and to Matt Hancock's
credit he actually pushed back quite
hard some of that was under pressure for
me but one of the good things about
working with him was that he did
completely get it in terms of what do we
need for this book to be really readable
and Pacey because the subject matter
itself couldn't be more serious you know
we're talking about the most seismic
political economic health events of our
times
as we all know tragically a lot of
people died so you know fundamentally
this is not a light-hearted story and
yet I didn't really want to write a book
which was about the race for the vaccine
which is what he initially envisaged and
I think Kate Bingham who is a vaccine
Tsar has done that very well
um I thought that it should be much
broader than that
um and I thought that diary form was the
most accessible to the most number of
readers and of course we're always
conscious of you know is this a secret
diary of Adrian Mall age 44 and a
quarter look I knew that we would get
that criticism so did he but then again
it was our best hope and Remains the
best way I think of bringing his story
to an audience that's beyond the
Westminster bubble quite and you
mentioned the breadth there uh there's a
whole number of topics in the book and
in the Articles you write about this
week what was the most surprising thing
you learned about sort of vaccines or
Care Homes what the really stood out to
you oh I mean the absolute Joy of this
project as a journalist which is what I
am first and foremost and through and
through was it's just story after story
after Story and you know if you you're a
political journalist as I am and you are
and you're immersed in this stuff what
you long for is that fly on the wall
detail that's really difficult to get
you only get it if someone has decided
just to splurge at all and that's what
he did so for me the the biggest thrill
was really in the detail it wasn't in
the headline Revelations of which by the
way there are plenty whether it's the
fact that they've genuinely thought
about releasing all prisoners except
perhaps the most tremendously violent
ones whether it's the fact that the
vaccine policy kind of morphed from
let's just vaccinate the vulnerable uh
and then it's Cry Freedom as he told
this very fine magazine uh into let's
attempt to vaccinate the whole
population and what struck me about that
as I've said in the piece for the
magazine is how little discussion there
was about the cost benefit of that
policy of this like for me that is the
greatest political goal post moving of
all times you know that whole okay we're
gonna vaccinate oh no actually we're
going to vaccinate the whole population
extraordinary
multi-billion pound economic
implications of that a policy and for me
much more importantly the Health and
Social consequences and one of the
really interesting things of course is
that you were quite a lockdown
absolutely it called a lot of this stuff
out at the time and subsequently Hancock
obviously was much more on the pro
lockdown side and I think the sense from
the book is very much that you know he
felt he would write about a lot of this
kind of stuff you must have a lot of
discussions with him and sort of he must
have gone over the details like you have
as well do you get any sense of uh of
either any emissions that either of you
are wrong at all and who was right
basically between you two I I obviously
obviously look I'm unconverted um you
know he knew from the start that I was a
lockdown skeptic I was pretty vocal at
the time
um and in some ways that is why I took
on this project you know my uh fellow
lockdown Skeptics and many of us had a
really hard time you know sticking our
neck out at a time when it was certainly
not fashionable to question lockdowns
and indeed one tended to be accused of
wanting people to die or being willing
to kill people and all these crazy
accusations
um so for those of us that have been on
what for many has been a painful journey
in terms of trying to express a
dissenting view
um some have looked at what I've done in
collaborating with Matt Hancock and
raised more than one eyebrow
um you know they have thought what is
Isabella shot doing working with this
figure that they see as is the architect
of everything that they abor the answer
to that is that journalists don't just
interrogate people they agree with
journalists shouldn't just work with
people they agree with on the contrary
you know without flattering myself who
better to go and interrogate Matt
Hancock and try to extract the maximum
detail as to what he was really up to
and what everyone else was really up to
then somebody who didn't agree with the
policy you know if he had worked with
somebody who was lapping it all up who
thought that the pandemic response was
pretty much as good as it could possibly
have been they wouldn't have asked the
awkward questions they wouldn't have
pushed to see yet another message yet
another document so that we could get as
much in there as possible and the fact
is that Matt still doesn't think that he
got it wrong and I I respect his right
to not think he got it wrong you know he
had all the information I believe that
he did the best he could in his mind
with the information that was available
but because he doesn't think he got any
of it wrong he was actually quite
surprisingly open to disclosure you know
he tended to be more in favor of
revealing than the opposite now of
course I can't know what I don't know so
I don't know what has been if anything
has been not told to me uh what where
the cover-ups may have come what I would
say simply is that I was pleasantly
surprised by how much I got that's very
interesting um and do you think that
that was more a sense of writing
retrospect or just right at the time was
there any kind of Contrition or perhaps
any kind of sense of
um we've got this one bit element wrong
but our intentions were right at the
time at all
um not quite enough as far as I'm
concerned
um look there are certain accusations
that genuinely seem to wound him because
he feels they are so unjust so the two
things he's most defensive on are Care
Homes and PPE contracts and contracts
for cronies and if I take them very
briefly in turn Care Homes I actually
find in his favor on that one broadly
he's often widespread accusation is that
he kind of blisely ordered the discharge
of elderly people from hospitals into
Care Homes without testing them properly
thereby seeding covers in care homes
with devastating consequences in reality
the testing capacity wasn't there he
clearly instructed Care Home operators
to isolate those patients I've seen the
documentation
and it was subsequently apparent by
independent Audits and so on that
actually the prime driver of infection
spreads in care was the movement of
Staff now politically from one home to
another that was really quite tricky
because the minute you start talking
about it actually being caused by staff
you get into a territory where everybody
you know hows with uh indignation and
says you're blaming the staff and and
that is exactly what's happened now
we've put that in the book and sure
enough Care Home industry is up in arms
but that was a reality and what was the
bpe as well the second one is PPE
um he gets really wild about this he
clearly genuinely doesn't think that he
has any response Bears any
responsibility for the awarding of
contracts to cronies
um and he was personally accused of
potentially profiting from a contract
that was awarded to his sister
um some I don't know what her company is
but actually when you looked at the
detail she had nothing to do with it I
think she was a subcontractor or
something it was in Wales and it really
wasn't nothing to do with him when it
comes to Michelle Moon I have seen some
of the correspondence on that and I have
seen him saying I I'm not using the
precise words here I'm paraphrasing I do
not want to deal with this woman it's
got trouble written all over it this is
me paraphrasing so he really dodged a
bullet on that one are there other
things that he did in relation to PPE or
other covert related contracts that I
don't know about that might come out I
can't rule that out but I really have
observed
um how upset this makes him and
genuinely when people are that riled
about something is because they think
it's an unjust accusation it's very
interesting one line in your piece of
the magazine was about social media and
the way in which I think that's very
much a debate that's still going on at
the moment with the Online safety Bill
going through Parliament and you say for
instance that one of my Hancock's
teamers have reached out to Twitter to
get them to change their algorithms as
early as January yeah what was the sort
of story run there and do you think
there's more to come out in terms of
obviously there's a debate in America
right now with what's going on with
Twitter do you know there's a sort of
debate coming on in the UK about what
how and where the social media Giants
versus the pressure perhaps by UK
government officials I think all of this
is really important because I'm of the
view this should never happen again
never again should an entire population
be subjected to repeated prolonged
lockdowns for a condition that didn't
actually pose a very very high mortality
risk to the majority of the population
of course it was very dangerous to some
people so I think it's vital that the
public health the inquiry the public
inquiry into the um the response is not
a whitewash and I think everything needs
to be on the table on that you know the
suppression of dissenting voices was
really serious and Matt Hancock would
defend this to his dying day and I will
argue the opposite that it was utterly
wrong to crush opposing views in the way
that they did I'm not saying it was
utterly wrong to make sure that people
didn't readily land when they were
Google searching the vaccine they didn't
immediately land on some crazy anti-vax
stuff that was genuinely
likely to undermine the public health
response or you know frighten people
quite unnecessarily but it was quite
wrong that real bits of information
backed up by real experts and clinical
studies or whether it's the yellow card
warning system for adverse reactions or
claimed adverse reactions was routinely
and systematically dismissed as medical
misinformation and people found that
they had their Twitter accounts
suspended and other social media I felt
very restricted on what I could and
couldn't question I mean this is
extraordinary and there are so many
repercussions now coming through I I
think people in this country are only
fully beginning to realize and we're
only on the cusp of that the devastating
long-term consequences for the economy
for health for our and most importantly
for our children of what we did but I do
say at the end of the piece in the
magazine that I think that the mistakes
on the part of our politicians were made
in good faith
but a good note to end on but I want to
ask you one final question is Matt
Hancock announced earlier today he's
going to be standing out of the House of
Commons you've worked with him closely
you've seen him go off to the jungle for
the I'm a celebrity you've seen uh you
know the revelations come out in the
Daily Mail and follow the serialization
just wondered what's next for Matt
Hancock well who knows I think it was
probably a wise decision on his part I
think so many of his generation of MPS
are Tory MPS are making that decision
you know Matt's still really young you
know he's in his early 40s I think he
could have a fantastic career in the
creative Industries after all he has
been culture secretary as well obviously
now has plenty of first-hand experience
of the TV industry but equally he might
go into the cryptocurrency world that's
one of his great interests or Finance so
look this is a guy whether you like him
or you don't like him
multi-talented as we discovered on I'm a
celebrity a full range of talents some
of which may or may not have much
application in the real world but I
don't think he's going to be short of
options Elizabeth thank you very much
joining us and thank you thank you TV
in Iran the protests are simply not
dying down even in the face of brutal
State suppression is that because the
country has moved away from Islamic
fundamentalism irrevocably Paul wood
writes on this issue in this week's
magazine and he joins me now
uh Paul welcome to spectator TV tell us
about what's going on Iran the protests
have fallen out of the headlines a
little bit um what's been happening
there well the protests have fallen out
of the headlines as you say but if you
talk to Iranian opposition groups as I
do there's a constant stream of videos
from across the country showing that
people are still out on the streets and
this is what is important and different
about these protests they're now in
their 11th week heading towards three
months more than 450 people killed 14
000 arrested these obviously are
opposition figures so we've had more
people killed in the past but I don't
think we've ever seen the longevity of
protests uh like these we haven't seen
them up and down the country at all
corners of Iran
um all ethnic and religious groups or
most of them in the regime's Heartland
as well as on the fringes and talking to
people who really know Iran and really
follow Iran they think this could be an
existential crisis for the regime this
is the biggest challenge in the opinion
of most Iran watches that the Theocratic
regime has faced since its Inception
and given all those challenges and the
regional spread the fact that there's so
much longevity what's the state really
doing in response to all of this well
they are moving very cautiously
um they have a Playbook which they've
used in the past which is to carefully
calibrate the violence until at some
point as in
um 2019 they decide now is the moment to
crack down and kill 1500 people
according to human rights groups in
three days back in 2019 so that is what
the activists are afraid of whether that
moment is coming because the regime
still has the guns they still have all
the tools of repression but another
reason why this protest is different is
because it is led by women and girls and
really the regime does not know how to
react to this uh what they fear doing is
sending a lot of police and paramilitary
forces out onto the streets uh and
attacking these young women
uh with batons and tear gas and live
rounds and causing a backlash uh you you
can sense the unease uh in this in the
some of the vacillating statements that
they've been from people in Authority in
Iran they don't know how to handle this
protest led by women as you say a very
different response if it was done by men
um well there's a lot of reports over
the weekend that Iran has abolished the
morality police
um Talk us through what exactly has
happened there because there's been some
conflicting reports about that
well the Situation's confused the
Attorney General appeared in remarks
that were interpreted in the west anyway
to say that the morality police would be
shut down
um this was not backed up by any other
member of the Iranian government and
local media began saying well what he
was talking about was the position in
law the formal position that the
ministry of justice and the attorney
general and the man who was speaking
didn't have direct control over them so
if this was the government's um shutting
them down or even putting up a trial
balloon that's a sign of the vacillation
and almost Panic that I was talking
about in my last answer this is the
regime you know really confronted with
the problem it doesn't know how to deal
with uh I don't think we can say the
morality police have been abolished um
this was either a misinterpretation or a
trial balloon this has not been backed
up by other elements of the government
but the important point is talking to
activists they don't care I mean this
started with a young woman being
arrested for what was called bad hijab
not concealing our hair properly and
then dying in a police station
um but it's gone beyond that and they
say that the activists say they're not
going to stop they want to go all the
way with this and get regime change
yes and you speak to a one called
Cassian uh in your piece uh she sounds
incredible uh what's her story explain
that to our audience well she's a member
of a small opposition group called The
pomi the wizard in Al hack the people's
budget of Iran which a long time ago
decades ago I had a brief spell when it
was
um part of an armed resistance hasn't
been that for a long time probably
doesn't carry that much weight inside
Iran um but is very good at organizing
and publicizing the message and a lot of
journalists like me speak to them she's
35 years old an accountant I don't think
we should have seen this as her real
name it's still very dangerous to speak
to Outsiders and the regime is so
worried about people speaking to
Outsiders that it's been slowing down
the internet such that it took me a
couple of weeks to get these answers out
of her messages passed backwards and
forwards rather than a live conversation
but she's been part of previous
uprisings and in her view in her words
this one is different because people
have shaken off the fear they've had of
the regime in the past now bear in mind
she's a member of an activist group this
is the kind of thing you expect the
activists to say and it's the kind of
thing that journalists like me have
heard in every previous demonstration
but there is a feeling as I say among
seasoned Iran watches that this time it
may be different it's been going on for
longer it's the element of women and
girls and the feeling that the regime
doesn't know how to handle this
and what can we in the west do you talk
about in your piece about sanction
Iranian oil is there anything the West
can do or is this purely a national
self-contained movement
or you know I've seen that he's calling
for us to invade Iran
um but there are there are degrees of
help and the most practical thing uh as
the piece says would be to
sanction the regime's sale of oil which
would cut off the money supply Joel
Rayburn who was in charge of Iran on the
U.S National Security Council a few
years ago under Donald Trump was telling
me that uh the Trump Administration got
the number of barrels of oil per day
being sold down to some 400 000 is now
about a million so that would cut off
the regime's money supply of course in
the short term if the regime thinks it's
survival is at stake and they give the
order to crack down
short of invading or arming these groups
on the street there is little that can
be done and so I guess you have to ask
also what's our Vital National interest
here well it would certainly be in the
interest of Western countries to have a
secular democracy in Iran but it is not
in the interest of Western countries to
have a civil war in Iran so certainly
Joe rayburn's opinion was that any help
which were to be given uh should be
given on the basis that the uh the
opposition remains United that again is
one of the new aspects of these protests
people do seem to be acting
um with unity across uh for instance you
know the the Kurdish Persian baluki
divide and it's another reason why these
protests are different but if the money
supply is cut off that's certainly what
um the activists want and they want for
instance the ircg to the the uh Elite
military forces of Iran to be listed as
a terrorist group in Europe as they are
now in the United States so a lot of
this is symbolic some of it cutting
their money off is real but ultimately I
think outside Powers cannot affect this
and Paul has a final question
um I'm aware obviously of the Follies of
making predictions but where do you see
uh these protests going and how long are
they going to continue for and what kind
of change if any will they bring
there have been many many process over
the years 2009
um huge protests that seemed to be on
the way to toppling the regime and it
didn't happen this is a regime which has
shown that it's prepared to do almost
anything to remain in power the
protesters don't have the guns they they
have
um perhaps the numbers on the streets
um Kathleen the lady that I spoke to
said something interesting she said that
going out on the streets uh looking into
the eyes even of the special forces the
most loyal troops the regime can command
she was seeing doubt in their eyes
people even casting their eyes down to
the ground
again that's an activist maybe somebody
um who wants to believe that
but once you get the security forces
flipping over that that's the moment um
for all of these authoritarian regimes
where things start to move
um we're hearing stories that they're
drafting in Iraqi militias sheer
militias from Iraq recruiting 15 year
old boys who are in paramilitary forces
a sign perhaps that they're worried
about the Loyalty of some of their
troops but you can never tell until the
collapse comes I wouldn't make any
predictions except that this is not
going to end quickly and that if it is
broken this time it will be back again
well Paul we should wait and see thank
you very much for joining me today on
spectator TV
now remember you can subscribe to
spectator this Christmas and get the
next 12 weeks of print and online access
as well a bowl of bulbridge air
champagne all for just 12 pounds this
offer is available to the UK only go to
www.spectator.co.uk forward slash Santa
to subscribe now then Harry and Megan
Netflix documentary is finally dropped
which is the latest attack from the
sussexes on the royal family they've
left behind it is cover article for this
week's issue our depth editor Freddie
gray takes a look at the warring
Windsors and he joins me now together
with the broadcaster and Friends of the
royal family Charles brandreth whose new
book is Elizabeth an intimate portrait
Charles brandreth Freddie gray thank you
very much for joining us on spectator TV
thank you um Freddie let's start with
your pieces you've written the cover for
this week's magazine War of the Windsors
and of course the the news angle here of
course is uh today the Harry and Megan
documentary has dropped on Netflix and I
think you've seen a bit of it so far
yeah I know the intelligent thing to say
is uh that you shouldn't watch it
because you shouldn't feed the monster
uh and that you have no interest in it
whatsoever but I'm a disgusting human
being so I watched it uh quite properly
this morning I also thought if I'm
writing about it I probably do have to
watch it and I will say that I think the
other smart thing to say about it
already is that it's very boring and it
is but at the same time it's
unbelievably hilarious
because it's it's accidental comedy gold
uh I mean it starts with Megan uh
sitting on a bed I think with a towel on
her head
um trying to make herself cry uh sorry
it's very cynical or upset let's say uh
and then it goes into a sort of long bit
about um them falling in love and
there's ridiculous sort of piano music
to sort of make you to manipulate your
emotions uh but actually I I think that
people watch this because they find it
very very funny
um and in fact it's almost a sort of new
genre of Comedy
very self-aware you never guess she was
a Hollywood star before this uh no well
I I sure I was thinking about that she's
not a very good actress that's the
that's the real problem she can't even
act herself
um would you say Hollywood star I have
American friends who are telling me that
it's not as big a story over there as we
may be playing it yes that in fact they
of course they're well known there but
it's not they're not front page they're
not numb first to Vision Stars they're
sort of Page Three or page five as a
rule so it wasn't
um overdo it because I'm a biographer of
the queen I rather like the queen I like
to think I can take the Long View
and I've been thinking about this and
actually reflecting it's the what we're
seeing the television thing is about
Harry and Megan it's not actually about
the really the royal family it's about a
family but it's not about the
institution of monarchy and at all
um and I think he must be aware of that
because of course his book is called
spare and it's a in some ways a clever
title you know an air and a spare but he
is the spare and that may be part of why
he's got problems uh Megan maybe why
he's got problems anyway he's got
sadness in his life and he's sharing it
with us but from the Queen's point of
view the great thing about being the
queen is she'd seen it all before and
you know the 1930s when she was a young
girl there was Edward VII abdicating to
marry his twice divorced American uh
then the 1950s there was all the Scandal
about Princess Margaret and wanting to
marry an older man who also was a
married man so kind of roller coaster
and I think the queen would have thought
this tool will pass and moved on and
thought well what's on the other side
because you know during her illness I
was told by the master of the household
at winter castle said she's been
watching line of duty and my role now is
as the explainer which is really very
funny because it's quite complicated but
she was trying to she was trying to
follow it no I was going to say uh David
Tang the late table Tang once told me
that um you know someone asked the queen
when the crown just come out if she was
watching that and um she would say well
I was there you know that was her life
so she wasn't so much fun of that um
Freddie one of the key sort of arguments
and fault lines has been about the
documentary has been about how William
and Kate are portrayed in this and she
wondered if you think that perhaps is
capable of perhaps the main target for
the sussexes and all of this that's what
people are saying I've only watched an
hour of it I think there's three hours
out now uh I certainly there's a sort of
attempt to say that there's all this
sort of um self-pitying stuff about the
Gilded cage you know they're all living
in this Guild occasion it's actually
very difficult to be a royal and all
that stuff which is a little bit
um uh sickening I think after a certain
point
um you know some people are born into
grinding poverty uh and
um I think they have
they've obviously they're trying to
suggest that Kate you know that they
sort of say uh you know Women Marry into
this institution Paris says I'm worried
about women marrying to this institution
this was actually in the trailer uh and
then there's a sort of shot of Kate
looking unhappy
um so they're obviously trying to
suggest that uh but it didn't feel like
it's going to go after her in quite the
way that some people seem to be
concerned about them
is almost a serious Point really in that
is is this is this introspection a good
thing uh I mean I first got into writing
about the queen through knowing the Duke
of Edinburgh because I was the chairman
of one of his pet Charities and he was
very keen on don't talk about yourself
people aren't interested they really
aren't interested and I know he told
each of his children I don't know he
said it to his grandchildren but as a
rule don't talk about yourself not
because it's a risk and it is a risk to
ask one question you answer one question
to a journalists they'll always ask
another it never ends but more actually
in life don't think about yourself ask
the other person what they're doing
people aren't interested in you and you
should be interested in them and his
philosophy was look up look out don't
think about yourself don't talk about
yourself get on with the job I think I
think it's fair say that's a lesson that
Harry and Megan have not learned well
the point is I think there will be the
unhappier because of it because the
queen of the Duke of Edinburgh lived
very long lives he lived in 99 she lived
in 96 and the queen was a happy person
driven by Duty we know sustained by
faith but made Happy by her passions for
her dogs and her horses that's what kept
her going she had interests outside of
herself same with the Duke of Edinburgh
he had so many interests same actually
with the king who is a workaholic has a
variety of real passions and great
television is not one of them
um but that's what makes people happy
doing other things that are outside of
yourself and I think the the problem for
them will be you know looking at
yourself in the long run I don't think
is a good thing do that really surprised
me by being so interested in Jung I mean
he surprised me a lot I mean for example
on his bedside he had the perjury of T.S
Eliot as bedside reading this is the
Duke of Edinburgh but he also was really
new about you and he said to me you know
young towards the end of his life did
some research on former patients and he
looked to the ones who were happiest for
the ones who were unhappiest and the
happiest ones were ones people who had
interest Beyond themselves in science in
nature in the world around them the most
unhappy were the people who are
introspective who were brooding about
themselves and that in a sense inspired
his projects like the juveniles award
scheme the Outward Bound trust all of
that
um and and so his line was there is
science behind this I'm not just saying
it but actually it's true that's
extremely interesting because
um Megan's podcast is called archetypes
and it's a sort of
um total sort of lobotomized
understanding of Jung not that I really
understand you but but that it's it's
actually every episode is supposed to be
about an archetype but it ends up being
Megan talking about herself again indeed
in front of in my book Elizabeth this
portrait in intimate portrait of the
queen I actually touch on that because I
was writing about
him and archetypes and one of the
developer's friends was telling me how
they got excited there was a big book
about archetypes written in the 1970s or
80s and they were very realized oh
actually this podcast is called
archetypes and it obviously is a
connection but it seemed to be a loose
connection so yeah because something had
gone wrong somewhere along the line I'm
not sure I think she's bright actually
but I'm not sure she knows what it means
what is interesting too is I do know for
a fact that the queen was very
encouraging to Megan at the beginning
and said to her which did surprise me in
terms you're an actress if you want to
go on working as an actress you must
that is your profession that is your
skill do that but Megan said no I want I
want to work for the Commonwealth so the
queen was very excited I want to be part
of this and and make it work the queen
then said well maybe as a kind of Mentor
so if a Wessex could help you and that's
when Megan said no I don't think so
thank you very much I've got Harry and I
think that's where it began to go well
in thinking oh well maybe it isn't to
work out that's why I wanted to ask
obviously with the queen with her Long
View I've seen many Outsiders coming
into that family how was she in terms of
sort of welcoming them in and how did
she see that sort of role of you know
sort of her children and grandchildren
marrying other people and coming into
the firm she was very good about that
she was very blessed herself in that
um she has made a good marriage when she
was young and knew that who she wanted
to marry she people think this is
actually it's quite amusing people think
that the queen first met the Duke of
Edinburgh in 1939 all the obituaries
state that all the biographers there was
their first encounter as the governor
said to me we were cousins both great
great grandchildren are Queen Victoria
we had met before and the idea that when
the queen was 13 and he was 18 it was a
love at first sight he's completely
Preposterous in his view but that's the
myth and that's what they want to say
that's what they will say his line was
that it didn't really become close until
towards the end of the war I think the
queen who certainly took a shine to
several other young men indeed as I show
in my book quoting letters from her
there was a cousin of hers rather too
close to cousin who she really admired
and thought was a very good marrying
Prospect he became a clergyman and I
think they would have got on extremely
well but anyway there was the Duke of
Edinburgh he was like a god he was an
Adonis and it worked but he was Royal so
he knew the way it worked he was a great
great grandchild of Queen Victoria so
though he was as it were from an outside
family from Greece he nonetheless knew
the way the system worked indeed he was
rather irritated when he was being shown
around Windsor Castle and to stay there
before he married the queen one of the
sort of Aquarius we're showing him he
said I do know that my way around here
my mother was born at Windsor Castle so
he wasn't incense an outsider who was
also an Insider but when it came to for
example her sister marrying Tony
Armstrong Jones who became Tony Snowden
and her children marrying outside of
royalty I think she was aware of the
problems and was very welcoming and I
know that with Megan she wanted to take
her and she did take her on solo
engagements so you can see how it's done
come with me and the first trip they
took them on was to my old constituency
the city of Chester so I thought this is
a very good idea but it turned out the
reason that the queen chose that she saw
on the program that she was asked to
open a theater in Chester so the queen
thought ah actress in the family come
with me and I have to say everybody who
was there including the Lord left-handed
to observed it the day said Megan was
superb she really delivered the goods
she was she stood as it were one step
behind the Queen the queen led the way
she was she'd never been to the north of
England before she said you know it's
the northern England
she coped with the windy weather but she
was impeccable and charming and
everybody loved her and so that was a
big success and there wasn't any kind of
sort of residual snobbery about an
actress entering the family at all or
anything like that none at all they love
show folk the queen I think
given another life the Duke of Edinburgh
told me if he had his way he wouldn't
have gone to the Navy at all he could be
perverse I mean you know whenever you
said his reply was yes but whatever it
was whatever it was yes but he also had
to contrary with you so he talked about
his service in the Royal Navy he was
mentioned yes but find me given my own
hand I'd joined the RAF that's what he
said the queen I genuinely think might
have become an actress seems
extraordinary thing to say because she
was quite shy as a person but I think
often shy people get Freedom when
performing and you remember how
brilliant she was only earlier this year
in that Paddington Bear sketch fantastic
but the queen I talked to the queen
about the Second World War
and that's for you what's memorable and
I and I think I prompted it by saying
Winston Churchill and she said of course
Winston Churchill then she said to me
you can research this I I don't know
whether it's true but I think that
Winston Churchill is the only uh person
who wasn't a member of the royal family
ever to stand in the center of the
balcony at Buckingham Palace I don't
think anybody else in history has ever
done so which is intriguing we can find
that out anyway so then went on to say
for me I suppose the happiest times with
a Christmas pantomimes
and for three for four or five years
they put on a Christmas show every year
at Windsor Castle she was in the lead
with Princess Margaret was produced by a
Headmaster from a local school that not
everybody liked uh and I said what part
did you play the principal boy said the
queen doing this
and uh she clearly adored doing it and
she said you know I I when they did
Cinderella I said who played buttons he
said we've written called him buttons we
called him something else and she told
me the name of the fellow and she said
oh I'm still feeling worried about this
um my sister and I we sent him a
telegram on the opening night from two
secret admires that's all we signed it
and we've wondered ever since whether he
realized it was us or whether he's
wondering who those two secret admirers
were so the queen was very in sympathy
with actors and actresses not
necessarily playing themselves you know
playing members of the royal family but
uh you know as a rule and Freddie on
that uh trip to America last week um
soon in the Boston Garden Kate and wills
um how do you think it's all gone down
with America because obviously you got
you got the Sussex is over in America
right now with their claims and um Katie
William over here how do you think the
perception of the royal family in
America have changed to someone who's a
long time Observer of the same there
well what what want one Insider said to
me that they had a Kennedy off uh and
and that William and Kate won because
William and Kate you know the Kennedys
are sort of American royalty
um in a disgusting way and uh they
um William and Kate met some senior
Kennedys the Elder Kennedys whereas
Harry and Megan got this award from um
rfk's seventh child and it was a sort of
made-up work gong called Ripple of hope
uh and um so yeah I think I think
Americans are interesting when it comes
to the monarchy because they have
totally different perspective on it and
actually I think Brits tend to think
that Americans take monarchy much more
seriously than they do we think that
they're obsessed with it and they're
interested in it and they are interested
in it but they also think it's a great
joke and that's where it comes to Harry
and Megan I think they are sort of
slightly all sniggering about it because
they're sort of seeing how far they'll
go down the path towards the car that's
an accidental comedy as you were saying
earlier yeah inadvertent comedy the
hilarity of it all two things to say
enriched in the Virgin comedy and Coney
Island once had an ice cream This is 40
years ago that I promised you was called
Ripple of Hope Ice Cream Coney Island
the other thing that happens not 40
years ago 50 years ago I traveled in a
lift with Robert Kennedy oh really by
mistake I didn't see the sign above the
lift saying Senators only
the Senate were you oh right I was a
student on the tour you know you did the
tour and the lift doors opened I stepped
in there was only one other person in
the lift it was Robert Kennedy so I
thought it was rather exciting Mr
Kennedy how exciting you mean the doors
were closing because he was pointing to
the sign that said Senators only I had a
brief encounter did you get out in time
so yes well I had I had to it was quite
exciting and also just I remember I'd
like to share this with you my trip with
Robert Kennedy was more he was more
forthcoming than when I went on another
lift trip with Michael Jackson oh well
now we're named Robin
with Michael Jackson and his minders and
it was a service lift he was in London
at the riba he was going to a book
launch his friend Urie gella the fellow
who bends the spoon was giving a book
launch and Michael Jackson was going we
were in the service lift together okay
so there I am so excited and probably
telling Michael Jackson I once traveled
to live with Robert Kennedy anyway he
doesn't respond he's he's there all
masked up before covet he was really
ahead of the curve he was all masked up
wearing a full Michael Jackson kit which
is not very big with this Burly mind you
know he didn't say a word got out of the
lip walked away and I said to his mind
as well that wasn't very friendly that I
was trying to be you know gracious and
admiring Mr Jackson he didn't say a word
and the mind has said to me it's a
Monday
Mr Jackson never speaks on a Monday
it's a good rule in life my wife says if
only you could adopt them
back to back to your subject now we're
just coming to our end unfortunately
just to feel like it's okay I think we
should do it we should do another whole
section on lift but that's
great
when eventually in another 20 years he
drops off the perch maybe I get a column
called lifts ups and downs social
climbing perhaps
very easy people I met on the way up
getting all the way down which is quite
such fun to see you do boys I've got I
mean we're probably running over time
now but I've got a good lift Story
related to the Senate oh good friend uh
so my old boss was a sort of she was a
hill reporter
um and she was Joe Biden who was then
the senator Center for Delaware walked
past and she would got there was a scrum
of people that he was involved in some
sorry didn't know what it was and uh
there was a scrum of reporters and she
was the only woman and she was sort of
being bustled about and Biden got all
gallant and said hey leave the lady
alone you know come come with me darling
you know and like brought her into the
lift the senator Senate lift and um and
then the door shut and she thought great
this is my chance to ask you lots of
questions and he got out of Snickers bar
and apparently inserted the whole
Snickers bar into his mouth and then
just masticated oh please throughout the
ascent yeah
um and uh and that's that's yeah that's
my live story so we could do an ups and
downs book should we do it again what is
this called spectator YouTube especially
the TV if this is what it's like I'm
going to be tuning in are you on every
week no no I think we should be honest
yeah and I like that honestly a whole
Snickers bar he's got a big mouth that
Biden yeah yeah amazing well the things
you learn I think coming on spectator TV
expected TV stay tuned it's a great
Channel I recommend it okay I mean who
needs GB news now we've got a spectator
TV Charles Freddie thank you very much
for joining me
and finally this is the first Christmas
since 2019 when coven hasn't been
foremost on people's minds so we'll
office Christmas parties come back with
a fury Cara Kennedy is certainly hoping
so she's written for the December issue
of spectator World about why she loves
these creations quite so much she joins
me now
uh Cara thanks for joining spectator TV
you've written for spectator World about
the Christmas party season uh you you've
written that you you hate Christmas but
you love the office Christmas party why
is that
it makes me sound really sad doesn't it
um well I have never been a fan of
Christmas
um I hate the idea of like that you have
to enjoy it and I was actually speaking
to Julie virtual the other day and she
was like I completely agree I want to
have fun all year round and then when it
comes to Christmas you feel like you
have to which automatically makes it
less fun
um so I was wondering about what I could
write about that's Christmasy because it
was for our December mag and then I just
uh it was the time that we were
arranging our Christmas party
um it was meant to be in New York but
now it's been moved to DC and I just
kind of thought about how Wild Christmas
parties are and how they're always
different to all the at least feel
different for me
um to any other kind of work event
why do you think that is exactly is it
just the time of year or is it the kind
of emotions that Christmas evokes or is
it a kind of licensed basically to let
your hair down and break down some of
the barriers in the workplace
I think it's a combination
um I think the timing is perfect because
it's the time of you where everybody has
um like two or three weeks off so you
can
um
kind of take yourself away from it a
little bit and and think about your
terrible behavior that you've done at
the Christmas party and yeah you just
kind of have that Breakaway
um obviously
in this industry especially
um it's very stressful tensions kind of
build up and then everybody's put in one
room at the Christmas party and it's
like chaos
um I've got to ask I mean you've started
writing for a spectator world but you've
been to a variety of office Christmas
parties which was your favorite one you
feed to
my favorite Christmas party probably the
telegraph last year because
um it's not so much what happened there
but it's the rumors afterwards so there
were rumors that I was like
can I swear on this
yep
slap dropping on um senior editors which
didn't happen but I found that rumor
absolutely hilarious so I was quite
happy that that went round
um yeah and that's another great thing
about Christmas parties especially in
journalism we're all like terrible
gossips we love like the most fallacious
stories so something can happen and then
it kind of snuggles into a bigger story
because we all love to tell stories uh
salacious Gotham I wouldn't know what
you're talking about but um no comment
you're the worst for right James I'm The
Host thankfully you spoke to us some of
your um your friends and columnists
about their their best Christmas parties
uh are there any we can repeat on air
without getting ourselves into trouble
um without ruining friendships or
perhaps anonymously
um I spoke to Julie
um obviously in the piece but when I
spoke to her
after that after I went to print she
told me about a lot more personalities
that she went to and there was one I
think it was the first Christmas party
she was like
18 maybe 17 which I probably shouldn't
say but um it was for the first
publication that she worked for and she
walked in the room and everybody was
given amphetamines which is like my
favorite story and um I think it shows
that uh kind of old school journalists
and younger journalists have just had
totally different
um experiences of Christmas parties
because you hear like the the grace old
Fleet Street days and they're a long
change from from what you see now that
was one of the questions I wanted to ask
you if you're in this generational
difference do you think there's perhaps
been a change in recent years perhaps
even post-covered and how we approached
the office Christmas party and what once
might have been you know very modest or
um or even more boozy Affair perhaps in
the sort of 90s or naughties is changed
at all do you think that's something
that uh is going to be a frequent issue
particularly when you look around a
different workplace office Norms in
other times that the offer Christmas
party could be affected by the the march
of time
yeah definitely and I think it's even
more sad for like people in their early
20s because a lot of them have have not
um have only kind of just started
working in offices again a lot of my
friends
um first jobs were from home and they
didn't really have their office
experience
um so to not even get together for like
Christmas is really sad and in the piece
I talk about how like one of the
tragedies of covid was that everything
was moved online and I mean you've done
Zoom quizzes they're hardly exciting
situations are they uh yeah so I think
um I think it is sad and I think you'll
see
um more and more young people are
missing out on situations like this I
mean I spoke to a friend the other day
who's Christmas party is going to be dry
so um it can be inclusive inclusive of
everybody and it's just like totally
ridiculous
I mean that's that I mean I think the
presence of alcohol is very much a
staple part I think it's almost as you
know what's Christmas without alcohol
but uh I was good do you think that um
the presence of that uh just changed the
the office Dynamics because of course
hierarchy is such a presence in the
workplace do you think that an office
Christmas party can never really get rid
of that sense of hierarchy in terms of
you know managers and and underlings Etc
um you must have seen a fair amount of
the breaking Downs of barriers of the
operations parties you've been to
yeah and I think it I think that's
another kind of generational thing
um so young people at Christmas parties
especially like um office based
Christmas parties go in and they're
really shy and they don't really know
what to do and it's always the older
um staff that straight away on the wine
um booster kind of dancing on the tables
and I think that that's the best part
because when your senior manager is
absolutely
in a hole in the corner
um it kind of allows you to loosen up
more but I think it's definitely
generational and I think that's
um because the older generation had such
great Christmas parties and young people
just don't really know what they're
doing yes I mean I went to my first
Christmas party when I was 17 and I
remember escaping the uh the Amorous
Embraces of two post-menopausal older
colleagues uh working at one of
Britain's leading High Street race
Realtors so that was quite an experience
for a pubescent James to do but
obviously talk about generational
differences but also there's you know
transatlantic ones and you're now there
in DC for your first Christmas party is
there a difference in how the Americans
approach these uh social Gatherings to
how we Brits do
oh my God there's such a massive
difference
um in the piece I speak today Julie
birchall and Christopher Bedford and I
couldn't have chosen to
uh to better foils for each other
because Julie is like let's get a
creative styler and get shit-faced and
Christopher Bedford is like
we're gonna have a martini bar a
Champagne Bar and really kind of has a
step-by-step guide of how his Christmas
parties go but um he's interesting
because he's lived in a house that has
had a very famous Christmas parties for
like decades and decades so he's kind of
got into a tea but even last night I
mean I went for dinner with um my editor
Zach and Ben Dominic and they were
talking about how some Christmas parties
they go to and they don't like it
because it's just beer and wine on offer
and I was like what more do you want and
they they're expecting to go places with
like martini bars and like different
stations and yeah it just shows that um
Americans definitely have higher
standards when it comes to Christmas
parties than our Spirits do
uh that was going to be my final
question really uh when it comes to
standards what are you most looking
forward to about your first American and
spectator World Christmas party uh
coming up later this month
oh my God I have the best answer for
this because I didn't realize but in DC
there's some bars left that you could
smoke in so that is my favorite thing
um and I'm gonna direct the party after
our meal to one of the smoking bars and
just sit there with a bottle of wine not
being able to see my colleagues through
the Smokey Haze and have so much fun
well good luck to all your spectator
world uh colleagues and surviving that
nicotine fueled Hayes Cara thank you so
much for joining us on spectator TV
thank you always a pleasure James
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to The Spectators
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss
another episode
finally don't forget to subscribe to The
Spectator this Christmas and get the
next 12 weeks of print and online access
as well as a bottle of Paul Roger
champagne all for just 12 pounds this
offer is available in the UK only go to
www.spectator.com forward slash Santa to
subscribe that's everything for this
week thanks again for watching and do
join us again next week
thank you